وقال الكلام لان الناموسكو لم تسمع اي
ادانه من الدول الغربيه بشان هجوم
المسيرات على العاصمه الروسيه وعرب الكريم
عن قلقه من عمليات قصف بالجوروت قائلا ان
سلاح الجو الروسي يعمل بشكل فعال لكن هناك
مجال لتحسينه وقال انه يجري حاليا اتخاذ
تدابير من دون تقديم تفاصيل اضافيه
وكنت قد اجريت مقابله مع ميخيلو بودولياك
كبير مستشري الرئيس الاوكراني وسالته عن
علاقه اوكرانيا بالهجمات بالمسيرات داخل
روسيا
نسعت بما يحدث في روسيا تعلمون اننا في
اوضاع الحرب منذ خمسه عشر شهر وما تقوم به
روسيا تقوم بالكثير من الاعمال العدوانيه
ولكن الحرب بتدريج تنتقل الى الاراضي
الروسيه لان هذه الحرب بهذه المساحه سوف
تنقلب عليهم لم يحاولوا حل المسائل بطريقه
سلميه اليوم ننظر كيف
تزداد وسائل الهجمات على روسيا بالمسيرات
طبعا ليس لاوكرانيا اي صله مباشره بهذه
الاحداث نحن ننظر لها بايجابيه من وجهه
نظر التنظيم هذه امور منظمه داخليا على
اراضي روسيه وروسيا تفقد السيطره على
مناطقها وتفقد
النظام وهذه الهجمات تزيد اثرها ويزيد
عددها ولكن
بحسب المعلومات الروسيه هذه الطائرات
المستخدمه الطائرات المسيره المستخدمه في
الهجمات هي من صنع اوكراني
كلا هذا ليس كذلك انهم لم يصنعوا اوكرانيا
انها مسيرات صغيره لا تطير لمسافات طويله
وانطلقت من مناطق محيطه لموسكو
واظهرت هذه الهجمات ان روسيا
ليست بالحجم والقدرات التي تعلن عنها ليس
لديها انظمه قويه
للدفاعات الجويه وليست لديها قدرات دفاع
الكترونيه ليس لديهم قدره على السيطره على
هذه المسيرات فلقد انطلقت من مواقع محيطه
لموسكو واظهرت نقاط الضعف حول موسكو
وحمايه موسكو لم يستطيعوا ان يتعاملوا مع
مسيرات بهذه البساطه عمليا هل لديكم اي
علاقه او معرفه او ارتباط بالمنفذين حتى
لو لم يكونوا
اوكرانيين هل انتم على علم بمن ينفذ هذه
الهجمات داخل روسيا
نعلم ان هناك الكثير من المواطنين الروس
الذين بداوا بتشكيل مجموعات معارضه مسلحه
مثل فيلق روسيا الحره او ارديكا هذه
المجموعات كثيره في روسيا ونحن نعرفها
ونعرف الكثيرين من المواطنين الروس الذين
مستعدون للقيام
بمعارضه مسلحه ضد النظام الروسي هناك
الكثير الكثير من هذه المجموعات وعددها في
تزايد وسوف يظهرون في مختلف المناطق
الروسيه والسبب
ان الحكومه وبوتين خسر سمعته وكل من يحيط
به ولان العمود
يعني اذا كنت عفوا اذا اذا كنتم اذا كنتم
تعرفونهم جيدا هل انتم مستعدون
لدعمهم
عسكريا وذل الادوات التي يحتاجونها من اجل
ان يشنوا هجماتهم داخل روسيا
اولا نحن لا نعلم كل من هو مستعد للهجمات
في الداخل الروسي من المواطنين هم يظهروا
بشكل متدرج ومن جانب اخر هم مستعدين لان
يحصلوا على او قادرين على الحصول على
مختلف الوسائل الضروريه للعمليات من
الجانب الثالث سوف نرحب باي ظواهر
للمعارضات الداخليه في روسيا
لن نتدخل طبعا في الاعمال التي يقوم بها
هؤلاء المواطنين الذين يعارضون نظام بوتين
لكننا لدينا هدف واحد هو تدمير القوات
العسكريه
المتواجده على اراضنا وسوف نستخدم كل
الوسائل لهذا سيد
روسيا اعلنت اليوم عن تدمير اخر سفينه
حربيه اوكرانيه
ما تعليقكم على هذا الاعلان
ان شاء الله
بدايه الحرب في بدايه
العمليات العسكريه قال الوزير وزير الدفاع
عنه دمر الاسطول البحري الاوكراني والان
نحن 31 من مايو عام 23 وهم يقولوا انهم
دمروا سفينه حربيه ان روسيا لا تعلن اي
معلومات حقيقيه هذا شيء معروف ان روسيا
تكذب باستمرار لا اعلم لماذا تقوم بعد
الدول وحتى الدول العربيه بالانصات لما
تقوله روسيا روسيا لا تتحدث عن الحقيقه
اما نحن نريد ان اقول ان اسطولنا البحريه
بخير وهو يقوم بكل المهمات الضروريه اين
اصبح الهجوم
المضاد هجوم الربيع قد انقض الربيع ونحن
على ابواب فصل الصيف ما هي العقبات التي
تحول دون شنه
اريد ان اوضح امور بسيطه جدا ضروريه لفهم
هذه الحرب هذه الحرب حرب مركزه ينضم لها
مئات الالاف من الجنود وهناك عشرات الالاف
من اليات الحرب منها الطائرات والمدفعيات
والمدرعات ليس هناك خطه مرتبطه بتاريخ
معين للقيام ببعض
العمليات الخاصه ان العامل الاساسي هنا هو
تجميع المعدات الضروريه للقيام بتقدم في
مختلف الجبهات
هجمات ممكن ان تكون مكونه من مختلف الجنود
مئات مئات الالاف منهم ايضا عوامل الطقس
يعمل
هنا الطقس هذا عامل مهم لان موسم الشتاء
كان طويل جدا
والرط التربه
لا تمنع المعدات من التقدم اما بالنسبه
لتخطيط السيناريو سيناريو الهجمات الذي
يعمل عليه الهيئه العسكريه العليا هذا شيء
اخر ان اوكرانيا تحاول تدمير الخطوط
الخلفيه للعدو حتى تمنعه من مد قواته
بالذخيره ولذلك نحن نقوم بضربات مدفعيه
على الخطوط الخلفيه نقصف المستودعات وخطوط
المد ومراكز تجمع القوات العسكريه كل هذا
يدمر يدمر الان حتى نقلل قدرات الجيش
الروسي